the white house is furious they're
really really upset that that babies
will live there will be babies today
who are not murdered in the state of
texas there will be babies today who
will go on and have a long life and in
10 and 20 years you'll be able to talk
to these babies who are alive because
this law is in effect and the white
house is furious about it they consider
it an extreme threat
on abortion
we've seen in a number of states
republican-led states an effort on
voting rights for instance to pass
similar legislation throughout the
country
on voting rights what's the level of
concern at the white house that the
decision
on texas specifically will lead to a
similar raft of laws across the country
and what is the recourse for the white
house at a federal level to help prevent
this well the step that can be taken is
for the is the codification of roe
something the president the vice
president have called for and would
require congress to act on uh i will
note that certainly we've seen this is
not the first threat to row we've seen
in a state across the country it's an
extreme threat and again i would just
note this is offering up to ten thousand
dollars to individuals who report
someone who is going to get an abortion
i mean that is what we're talking about
here so and and beyond that as i've
already outlined
based
to use the lingo of the kids
based awesome great love it it's a this
is a great great way by the way you're
gonna hear that this
this law is punishing women it's going
to throw women in jail it's not it's not
you're not you don't get to sue the
women you sue the abortionists and you
sue the little minions of the
abortionist and you sue all the
and the peop men paying for the
abortions you get to sue all of them
those are the people who are targeted
here and it
is an extreme threat to roe versus wade
what jen saki's admitting here by the
way is that roe versus wade is a
ridiculous decision
that's her admission when she is asked
by this
leftist activist reporter saying how do
we stop it how do we stop it
you say she says well what we have to do
is codify roe vs weight into law
why do we have to codify roe versus
white into law because it's a weak
decision there is no constitutional
right to an abortion even if you're the
strongest abortion supporter in the
world it just isn't there it just
doesn't exist and and even
the intellectual and the intellectually
honest leftists who support abortion
and look at roe versus wade they will
tell you the case does not have very
much constitutional merit so now they're
saying we need to codify it into law you
have to codify into law because because
it's a ridiculous decision and if there
is justice even a little bit of justice
in this world it ought to be overturned
cnn freaking out about this they've
brought on their chief legal analyst
jeffrey toobin
jeffrey toobin has a a lot of personal
expertise on creepy sex questions as you
will recall
he lost one of his jobs uh some months
ago because he was caught um
having sex with someone he loves on
camera on a zoom meeting with his
colleagues
so
jeffrey tubin but and that that event
involved one person
other than the spectators so jeffrey
twomin is back on cnn
and jeffrey toobin often like i do on
this show we don't do that we don't have
that in common but one thing we do have
in common
is that occasionally on air we will say
i told you so and jeffrey toobin did
tell you so when it came to roe versus
wade donald trump ran for president
saying i will appoint justices to the
supreme court who will vote to overturn
roe v wade he has three appointees on
the court there are three other
appointees on the court uh samuel alito
uh
clarence thomas and robert and john
roberts who have spoken out against roe
v wade before although roberts has later
said he supports the president but there
are five justices it appears the three
uh
uh uh trump appointees plus uh there
they are on the screen plus thomas and
alito who seem like solid votes to
overturn roe v wade
you know that we've been accused those
of us who have been saying that roe is
about to be overturned as being chicken
little the sky is falling the sky and
falling we'll see because it certainly
looks like the sky is falling now the
sky is falling
because fewer babies will be killed in
texas
don't forget you're going to be told
that women have a right they have a
sacred constitutional natural right to
kill their children they don't they
don't they don't have that right
but you're gonna be told only focus on
this only focus on the poor abortionist
who's just trying to scrape by and feed
his family by by committing infanticide
at planned parenthood just think about
him
don't forget
this involves a baby
and that's not just an abstract it's not
just a hypothetical
there will be babies
who are permitted to live because of
this law
and you will have to look them in the
eye
at least on camera they'll look at you
you'll see them
and you will have to explain at least to
yourself why you think that it would be
better if they were killed why you think
that it's wrong that they were permitted
to live
jeffrey tubin's going to have to do that
but jeffrey tuban is an abortion
supporter
not just in theory he tried to pay off
his mistress to kill his child and his
mistress wouldn't do it now he's got the
child and he's gonna have to look that
kid in the eye someday if he has a
relationship with that kid and explain
why he tried to kill that baby
and why he still supports the the right
quote unquote
of people to kill babies just like him
all over the country
i love raicons they are a better product
than
some of the other brands on the market
all right i'm going to try to be nice
about it but you know look ray guns they
don't have the little stem sticking out
so you don't look like a bug they don't
only come in one color they come in a
lot of cool stylish colors great
fit of their gel tips for your comfort
they sound better they work better
they've got a 32 hour battery life i
love my ray guns okay
and especially
when my sweet little baby starts crying
you know whether i'm in the house maybe
we're on a plane or in the car
it's nice to know that i can just pop in
my raikons and have a nice little bit of
peace and quiet they're really great to
start half the price of other premium
audio brands but they sound just as good
they actually sound better if you ask me
raycon's comes with a 45 day happiness
guarantee so you really can't lose give
them a try you will see what i mean
great way to listen to really good
audiobooks like speechless
create your own soundtrack with raycon
right now my listeners can get 15 off
their raycon order at buyracon.com
knowles that's by raycon dot com slash
knowles say 15 on raycon you're going to
love them tell me how much you love them
buy raycon.com
knowles
cnn's legal analyst jeffrey toobin is
really upset about the new texas
pro-life law
it because he supports the abstract
right to abortion and also because he
has tried to pay to procure abortions
himself according to this law if he did
what he has done in texas he could be
sued
for at least ten thousand dollars plus
attorney fees
so he's got a real personal interest
here in making sure that these babies
don't get to live
and now he's going after the court he's
trying to sway the court and so he goes
on television and he says look the
institutional reputation of the court is
at stake here
here we are on september 1st the first
day
since 1973
when a state has been able to ban
abortion 1973 is the year of roe v wade
and
the supreme court has said nothing they
have allowed the second most famous
opinion of the last hundred years after
brown v board of education to
essentially be violated be of be overrun
but
they haven't even said a word about it
which strikes me as a real blow against
the supreme court's institutional
reputation aside from the issue of
whether this law is right or wrong
a real blow against the supreme court's
reputation regardless of whether the law
is right or wrong
i don't think that's true
you know what i think was a blow against
the supreme court's reputation roe
versus wait
i think roe v wade was a huge blow
against the court's reputation because
it showed that the court was nothing
more than a a partisan political
lawmaking body rather than a judiciary
i think that aside from the issue of
whether you think abortion is right or
wrong i think we all should be able to
admit roe vs wade
was the attack on the court's reputation
and they can either make that right now
or they can persist in error and
humiliation
and degradation of the court
there's a woman some brooklyn chick
who's apparently a medical doctor
her name is dara cass and she i think
she shows you some of the hysteria
you're going to see from the left media
on this issue she tweeted out
get on birth control now
any form that is reliable oral
contraceptives nuvaring nor plant iud
something now
now hurry
so
what she's admitting here is that the
left uses abortion as birth control as
contraception but it's obviously not
contraception because the baby is
conceived and then they just kill it
what she's admitting is there are a lot
of
leftists who are so cavalier about
abortion about killing babies that they
don't even they won't even put on a
condom they won't even they will that's
all right we'll just deal with it later
with abortion
the left tells us they don't do that but
then she's just admitted they do
beyond that point beyond that point
get on birth control now anything oral
cut nouveau ring i.u.d do something i
i've got i've got another idea how about
you just have babies like they do in
normal civilizations that are not dying
how about you just do that i know this
is a crazy radical idea how about you
just like
be open to life
and have babies and actually fully give
of your love to another person and then
make your life better by having a baby a
lot of people can't have babies it's a
hard there are a lot of people who
struggle with infertility okay
who would who would give their limbs who
would cut off an arm
at least to have a baby
and this cavalier woman you know we are
a dying civilization i mean that in a
very technical way we we are not having
enough
children to continue as a civilization
and this has been true for decades now
and it seems to be getting worse and
worse each year and other civilizations
are having babies because they're lively
and we're dying and we're decayed and
something's gone really rotten within us
which is how you get
creepy statements like this this woman
goes on she goes
if you find out you're pregnant and do
not want to be you have very little time
to do it do not shut down this will be
hard but you can't delay call me we will
figure this out together what a psycho
this woman is saying call me and i will
kill your child this is what demons
sound like
okay this is
if you want to know you read the bible
or you you read accounts of demons
throughout history and in stories in
myth in in history in real stories
so what does a demon sound like a demon
sounds like that lady
call me call me now don't let it don't
let them stop you from killing i'll help
you i'll kill your baby give me your
baby
good grief lady
what this is scary stuff and
i mention it i mean it's so obvious with
her
but you're going to hear this kind of
stuff from a lot of people
you know don't forget who the prince of
this world is okay
don't forget this is a fallen world
there's a lot of bad stuff here but
you're going to hear these same kinds of
things from people in the media from
politicians maybe from people you know
when you hear it
one don't be seduced two maybe try to
change their mind three flee from that
that is
you were playing with some bad juju my
friends
[Music]
[Music]
you